Mind Your Decisions, I'm Presh Talwalkar.
In square ABCD
construct a quarter circle centered at A whose radius is equal to the side length of the square.
Construct a circle P inside the quarter circle that is tangent to both the quarter circle and the square
Finally construct CE
such that CE is tangent to the inscribed circle. The question is what is the measure of angle ECD?
Pause the video, if you'd like to give this problem a try and when you're ready keep watching to learn how to solve this problem
Recall that if two circles are tangent their centers and the tangent point are collinear
This is because AC is perpendicular to the tangent line and BC is also perpendicular to the tangent line
Therefore ACB forms a straight line segment.
This is true for both externally and internally tangent circles.
Now, let's solve the problem
We have a quarter circle centered at A and we have an inscribed circle P that's tangent to it
Therefore AP and the tangent point will be collinear
Since A is a corner of the square this line segment will also go through C the other corner of the square
Suppose the inscribed circle has a radius equal to r
Construct PQ such that Q is the tangent point alongside AD
PQ will have a length equal to r
Now construct the perpendicular radius, which will also have a length equal to r. This means AQ has length equal to r.
Thus AP is the hypotenuse of an isosceles right triangle and its length will be equal to r times the square root of 2
We then have the radius of the quarter circle is equal to r square root of 2 plus r
This means AD will have the same length and thus QD must have a length equal to r times the square root of 2
Now let's consider the diagonal of the square
This must be equal to the square root of 2 multiplied by the side AD
We can substitute in for the length of AD and then simplify
we know the length of AC and
We know that a portion of it is equal to r plus r times the square root of 2
Therefore the remaining portion must be equal to r
From here. Let's construct CE
Since E is a tangent point we must have P. EC is a right angle
Then PE is equal to R because it's a radius of the circle
now consider the right triangle PCE
We have hypotenuse that's equal to 2r. And a shorter leg that's equal to r
Therefore the angle opposite r must be 30 degrees because this is a special right triangle
This means PCE is equal to 30 degrees
We can finally calculate the measure of angle ECD
It'll be equal to angle ACD minus angle PCE
Angle ACD is equal to 45 degrees and angle PCE is equal to 30 degrees .
Therefore, angle ECD is equal to 15 degrees and that's our answer
It's a cute little geometry problem. Things are making mind your decisions
One of the best channels on YouTube as always. Thanks for watching and thanks for your support